Hello. Welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A
where your questions will meet God's
word. We're in a world with so many
shifting opinions, so many opinions, so
many things going around about the word
of God. But today, you're going to get
your questions answered from the true
source that is eternal that will give
you the answers. Well, my name is Angela
Lomang, and I'm glad that you've tuned
in. You're going to be blessed. Grab
your Bibles, a pen, and just write some
questions down, and I'll give you the
information in a few minutes on how you
can get in contact with us here at 3ABN.
Thank you for your prayers and your
support of this worldwide ministry. We
are looking forward to that glorious day
of Jesus is soon appearing. And I hope
that you will be there also. Well, we
have a wonderful, illustrious panel. I'm
going to start with our wonderful
sister, Shelley Quinn. Welcome, Shelley.
>> Angie, it's good to have you here and
we're so glad that you've joined us.
Thank you for sending in your questions.
>> Do you enjoy this program?
>> Yes, I do.
>> Amen. Pastor Daniel Maronei, welcome.
>> Thank you so much for welcoming me and
thank you for sending your questions in.
It's always a blessing. Thank you so
much.
>> That's right, my sweetheart, the love of
my life. That's right,
>> Pastor John Lang. Well,
>> back to you, babe. It's always good. And
thank you for the challenging questions.
We don't know what you're sending, but
every time you send something, we learn
something.
>> Yeah. And these the wonderful panel,
they dig into the word of God. And we
always pray before we go on the air and
we're going to pray while we're on the
air. So, I'm going to ask Sister Shelly
to offer a word of prayer.
>> Oh, absolutely. Father, we thank you so
much for our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ, for your Holy Spirit in your
word. And now as we delve into your
word, uh I know that you have anointed
us and led us during the preparation, we
pray that help us to get these answers
out in our aotted time. And may everyone
who hears
uh be satisfied that this is your truth.
We love you. We praise you. And we thank
you. In Christ we pray. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Maybe you've just tuned in.
You're thinking, hm, how could I send a
question in? Well, you can send qu your
questions in. We have three ways that
you can do so. You can email us at
bibleqa3abn.tv.
Well, you may want to text us. You can
text us at 6182283975.
Maybe you're an Instagram person. You
can send that question by at 3ABN
official. So you can send your questions
in. All right, let's start with you,
honey. Pastor John.
>> Okay,
>> here's your first one. I have been told
by someone in the church that when a
loved one dies, it is wrong to have them
cremated. But then there are others in
the church who do have their loved ones
cremated. Is cremation wrong? This is
from Darla in Oregon.
>> Okay. Well, somebody once termed
cremation as uh the life of someone
going up in flames. Mhm.
>> Um the Bible doesn't say it either way.
Uh the Bible doesn't say cremation is
right or cremation is wrong. But if you
look at the cadence, uh the Bible's not
against cremation. Uh though cremation
turns us to dust a lot quicker.
>> You know, we are told from dust you are
to dust you shall return. But cremation
gets you there a lot faster. Now, I
looked at some Bible uh I would call
them rhythms about burial compared to
cremation. And in the book of Genesis
chapter 3, uh Abraham buried Sarah. He
didn't cremate her. Uh Jacob requested
burial in Genesis 49 29-33.
Joseph made Israel promise to bury his
bones. And then we also have Jesus was
buried in a tomb. So you have four
examples of burial. Uh then if you look
at the other side of that in scripture,
burning bodies is frequently associated
with dishonor and divine judgment. I'll
give you one example. You find Achen uh
stoned and burned after he was condemned
for his sin and how it affected Israel.
That's in Judges 7:25. And then
Leviticus 20:14,
burning is connected to punishment. Amos
2:1, Moab was condemned for burning the
bones of those who had died. So burning
in the scriptures are often connected to
an act that's not favorable. And then
finally, you find here in Revelation
20:9 speaking about the wicked. They
went up on the breath of the earth and
surrounded the camp of the saints in the
beloved city and fire came down from God
out of heaven and devoured them. So, the
Bible is not for or against, but um my
wife and I have made a pack. Whichever
one of us goes first, uh don't throw
don't throw me on a match or don't throw
a match on me. Uh it's something that
traditionally in some cultures it
doesn't really matter. In other
cultures, it's a it's a matter of honor.
I think in a lot of West Indian
cultures, it's something that they don't
even think about. But it also is very
economical if you think about it. And
the question is, can Jesus resurrect
somebody that is cremated?
>> Absolutely. Well, let's see what the
Bible says. When Martha was concerned
about her brother Lazarus in John 11:25,
Jesus said, and this applies to whatever
condition you are in after you die, I am
the resurrection and the life. He who
believes in me, though he may die, yet
shall he live. So, it doesn't matter.
Jesus is not limited by Well, you know
what?
>> They turned to us. No,
>> because he told Adam in Genesis 3:1 19,
"In the sweat of your face, you shall
eat bread till you return to the ground,
for out of it you were taken. For dust
you are,
>> and to dust you shall return."
>> That's right.
>> Cremation just speeds up the process.
And so the answer is, is it right or
wrong? It's neither. It's a matter of
preference. But no matter what the
condition, some people die in the ocean,
some people die in fires, some people
die in crashes. All different ways
people die. But in all those, Jesus is
still the resurrection and the life.
>> And it's a choice. You want to be
cremated. It's a choice.
>> You know, it doesn't mean that you're
lost.
>> That's right. And a beautiful s a
beautiful casket doesn't mean you're
saved.
>> That's right.
>> You know, it's all about the and Jesus
Christ.
>> Okay. All right. Pastor Maronei,
I was speaking to someone about natural
disasters and I was making note that
they have been happening more frequently
now and with a lot more intensity.
The person stated that they saw videos
recently that had a lot of the natural
they said that a lot of the natural
disasters are man-made
based on what they saw on Tik Tok.
>> And they directed me to First Kings 19
11-13.
Can you explain these verses to me
please? This is from Michaela in
Jamaica.
Michaela, thanks for that question.
Well, let me say something about natural
disasters being man-made. You know, I
looked up and found that Tik Tok does
have a lot of videos that have gone
viral.
>> You know, I did some research and found
out that a lot of factchecking has been
going on regarding man-made earthquakes.
The BBC, the CBS News, YouTube, Voice of
America, DW, which is a German affiliate
or outlet, and then others all say that
it's actually fake news.
There are AI generated videos and
conspiracy theorists rampant on social
media and it's recommended to check the
source of the information. Fear and
conspiracy are powerful motivators and
the more views that are generated on
these media platforms, the more income
that the creators of these videos make.
So as for this Bible text in first Kings
chapter 19 beginning with verse 11, this
is actually the story of Elijah. It was
right after the showdown on Mount Carmel
there where the fire came down probably
the earth quaked also and um
but after that happened you know that
really high day there Elijah
um got depressed because Jezebel says
I'm going to kill you. So he ran for his
life a 100 miles became so discouraged
and depressed that he wanted God to take
his life.
>> So the text reads this way. This is God
talking to Elijah and he said go forth
and stand upon upon the mount before the
Lord and behold the Lord passed by and a
great and strong wind the mountains and
break it in pieces the rocks before the
Lord. But the Lord was not in the wind.
And after the wind, an earthquake. But
the Lord was not in the earthquake. And
after the earthquake, a fire. But the
Lord was not in the fire. And after the
fire, a still small voice.
>> And it was so when Elijah heard it that
he wrapped his face in his mantle, and
went out, and stood in the entering in
of the cave. And behold, there came a
voice unto him, and said, "What doest
thou hear, Elijah?"
>> Mhm. When it says that the Lord was not
in these demonstrations of power, the
wind, earthquake, fire, it doesn't mean
that they were man-made. God was trying
to encourage Elijah who had become so
discouraged because after that huge
display of fire coming down from Mount
Carmel, he thought there would be a
great revival and everybody be changed
and here they're wanting to kill him.
>> So there was no demonstration of
repentance from God's people, Israel. We
read in Zechariah 4:6 where it says,
"Not by might nor by power, but by my
spirit, sayeth the Lord of hosts."
That's who actually converts someone.
>> So, you know, if your pastor does a
powerful sermon and nobody changes,
>> he might get discouraged.
>> Listen to what he says and be converted.
Thanks for the question.
>> All right. Thank you, Pastor Maronei.
Okay, Shelley, you have a very short
question. Is it right for a man to marry
an older woman? This is from Yah Y A W.
>> Yah. I'm just going to say yes if it is
Christ centered spirit uh spiritually
unified and entered prayerfully.
Scripture
consistently evaluates marriage by
faithfulness to God. It rarely records
the age of a woman when they're married
and even more rarely compares the ages
of the husband and wife at marriage.
There's no prohibition, warning, or
negative judgment against marriage
between a younger man and an older
woman. So
anywhere that God has not prohibited, we
should not condemn. Romans 14:4 reminds
us, who are you to judge another man's
servant?
>> The age difference, whether a woman is
older or younger,
>> is not sinful if the marriage honors
God. Scripture frames marriage around
ethics, not around age, order, but
covenant, faithfulness, character, and
God's calling.
>> Marriage exists to glorify God and to
strengthen faith.
>> His design,
>> the marriage focus is on oneness. The
marriage focuses on mutual support, not
age. Jennifer Gen Genesis 2:24.
Therefore, a man shall leave his father
and mother and be joined to his wife,
and they shall become one flesh. They
are jointed, joined, not just
physically, but spiritually. In Matthew
19:4-5, Jesus said, "Have you not read
that he who made them at the beginning
made them male and female and said, "For
this reason a man shall leave his father
and mother and be joined to his wife,
and the two shall become one flesh." So
God's design is one male, one female,
because the law of life demands
reproduction. And they are truly united
when they have a child. That child is a
perfect union of them if you would. So
in choosing a partner, scripture
prioritizes
shared faith and values and character
because you want to walk in unity in
your covenant of purpose and action.
Amos 3:3 says, "Can two walk together
unless they are agreed?" in 2
Corinthians 6:14 says, "Do not be
unequally yolked together with
unbelievers." So, Proverbs 18:22
says this, "Yah, he who finds a wife
finds a good thing and obtains favor
from the Lord." If you are marrying a
Christian woman who you know that the
two of you can walk together in unity,
>> if she's older,
don't worry about it.
>> Exactly. And you have a good man. She's
married to a good man also. Like I'm
married to a wonderful all three of all
of us here are married wonderful
spouses. Thank you, Shelley, for that.
>> Okay, Pastor John.
Is it wrong to listen to or follow
biblical programs
programs from nonadventist churches? If
so, how can I get a Bible study plan
from my favorite channel, 3ABN? This is
from Joseph in Kenya.
>> Joseph, thank you for that question.
Well, I'll answer the latter part first.
Just contact 3ABN. We have a lot of
great resources. Uh we have some online.
Uh there's some Bible references you can
find out about where there are questions
that have already been answered. And
3ABN has its own Bible study program, 27
lessons. Am I correct, Shelley?
>> And that's available online for
>> and it's available online also. So right
away that part is already answered.
>> But it's not right or wrong. It's
amazing. Both of my questions today
started with is it wrong? It's not right
or wrong, but the question is what are
you looking for? If you're looking for
entertainment,
the stage is broad. If you're looking
for lights, camera, action, and feeling,
the stage is broad. But Jesus
established a a parameter.
>> And I'm gonna bring those parameters out
to you. John 4:23 and 24. He says,
he says, um, God is spirit, and those
who worship him, well, let me just go
the whole thing. The hour is coming, and
now is
>> when the true worshipper must worship
the father in spirit and in truth, for
the father seeketh such to worship him.
God of spirit and those who worship him
must worship in spirit and in truth.
Those are two parameters. Now, let me
just break them down. A lot of people
say, "I'm filled with the Holy Spirit."
>> But the only evidence of that is, are
you following and teaching the truth?
>> Many people want the emotion, but they
don't want the scripture. And it's very
important that we not determine what we
hear as true if it just makes us feel
good or if it's a really tight program
or music is good because there's so many
distractions nowadays. And the Bible
also point out in Matthew 7:15, beware
of false prophets who come to you in
sheep's clothing but inwardly are
ravenous wolves. So don't make it based
on wow that person looks credible.
Everything must be measured by the word
of God. Jesus did that in in the
wilderness of temptation. Every time
that Satan tried to tempt him, he said,
>> "It is written. It is written. It is
written." So, examine it by the word of
God. The second thing is, if you
determine to be a commandment keeper,
this is a prerequisite to receiving the
Holy Spirit. Let me make that very
clear. John 14:15 is not by itself. John
14:15 is followed by John 14:16. If you
love me, keep my commandments and I will
pray the father and he will give you
another comforter that he may abide with
you forever. Why is it important to be
obedient? Because Acts 5:32, God gives
his spirit to those who obey. Today,
there's a lot of religion, but not a lot
of obedience. A lot of emotion, but not
a lot of adhering to God's word. So, if
somebody says, I know, for example,
let's just use the Sabbath. I know the
Sabbath is true, but run to the hills
>> because obedience to the word of God is
a guard. It's a sword. It's a shield.
It's a buckler. Psalm 91, your truth
shall be my shield and defense. So, is
it wrong? No. It depends on what you're
looking for. Let the word of God guide
you to what you should watch.
>> Beautiful. Well said. Thank you for
that.
>> Okay, Pastor Mooney.
How do you discern when God is talking
to you or giving you a vision versus
Satan? This is a viewer from a viewer in
Virginia.
>> Well, that's a really important question
and a popular question, too. People want
to know, you know, should I buy a
lottery ticket or all kinds of other
things, too. They want to know.
>> Well,
um, we ask ourselves, is this God
speaking to us? Mhm.
>> We have the scripture in John 10:27
which says, "My sheep hear my voice and
I know them and they follow me."
>> And earlier in John 10, we read starting
in verse two where Jesus is speaking,
"But he that enterth in by the door is
the shepherd of the sheep. To him the
porter openeth, and the sheep hear his
voice, and he calleth his own sheep by
name, and leadth them out. And when he
puteth forth his sheep, he goeth before
them, and the sheep follow him,
>> and they know his voice. That's the key.
Know his voice. And a stranger will they
not follow, but will flee from him, for
they know not the voice of strangers.
>> So, how do we know the voice of someone?
You know, Valerie and I have been
married over 50 years. We pretty much
know what's going to please or upset
each other. And so, the more we listen
to somebody, the more we recognize them.
And you'll notice that the more you read
God's word, the more you'll discern when
something just doesn't seem right. When
it says no, it's actually referring to a
relational relationally intimate and not
a casual acquaintance. We need to seek
Jesus. Seek to know him.
>> And when you know him, you'll become
like him.
>> And when you become like him, you're
going to do what he would do. Quoting a
famous author, all true obedience comes
from the heart.
It was heart work with Christ. And if we
consent, he'll so identify himself with
our thoughts and aims. So blend our
hearts and minds into conformity to his
will that when obeying him, we're going
to be just carrying out our own
impulses. The will refined and
sanctified will find the highest delight
in doing his service. When we know God
>> as it's our privilege to know him, our
life will be a life of continual
obedience.
You know, one final thought, it seems
like most of the time that you have
peace when you're listening to and
obeying God's voice. Mhm.
>> In Isaiah 26:3
it says, "Thou wil keep him in perfect
peace whose mind is stayed on thee
because he trustth in thee." Thank you
again for that question. Blessing. Amen.
That's right. Thank you, Pastor Mooney.
Okay, Shelley, another short quick
question.
What is Matthew 7:6 talking about? This
is from Michaela in Tennessee.
>> Michaela, context, context always
matters.
>> So if you look at Matthew 7 uh verses
1-5, it begins with judge not. This is
instruction not to judge harshly or
unfairly with self-righteous
hypocritical kind of judgment. It's
warning us not to be intolerant or act
superior. And verse six is basically
saying we shouldn't judge hearts, but we
should still exercise spiritual
discernment when we're presenting
holy truths to those who hate truth and
mock you. So let's look at it. Matthew
7:6, "Do not give what is holy to the
dogs, nor cast your pearls before swine,
lest they trample them under their feet
and turn and tear you to pieces." So
what are holy things and pearls? Holy
refers to the sacred spiritual truths,
the gospel, God's law, Christ's
sacrifice, and the deep things of the
kingdom. In Psalm 25:14,
it says, "The secret of the Lord is with
those who fear him, and he will show
them his covenant." Now, pearls
represent precious truth revealed by
God, not common opinions or arguments.
Romans 11:33 says, "Oh, the depth of the
riches both of the wisdom and the
knowledge of God."
So basically what Jesus is saying don't
judge hearts but do exercise wisdom in
how and when you share sacred truth. So
who are the dogs and the swine? This is
symbolic language
>> that is describing those who
persistently mock, despise or abuse
sacred truth. It's not about un
unbelievers who are seeking
understanding. It's about people who
repeatedly show a hardened resistance
and hostility and contempt. Proverbs 9:7
says, "He who corrects a scoffer gets
shamed for himself, and he who rebukes a
wicked man only harms himself." In Acts
13:45,
it says, "When the Jews saw the
multitudes, they were filled with envy."
As the multitudes came to hear the
disciples, they were filled with envy
and contradicting and blaspheming. They
opposed the things that was spoken by
Paul. So the Jews rejected the holy
truth of the gospel and guess what? Paul
turned to the Gentiles. So there's a
principle here. We must be responsible
witnesses. The Bible teaches us that we
must be share truth according to
readiness. Sometimes people aren't ready
to hear. And even Jesus sometimes
withheld deeper truths because hearts
weren't ready. Sometimes his own
disciples weren't ready.
>> So do not turn evangelism into a heated
argument.
>> Nobody's winning. No,
>> that's fruitless. Our mission is to sow
seed, not to force the soil to receive
it. Now, I have to point out Matthew 7:6
does not count uh cancel Christ's
command to love all people that he said
in Matthew 5:44. Love always governs our
response.
He's teaching us to love wisely by
stepping back when truth is trampled and
praying for the spirit to prepare hearts
waiting for God's timing.
>> Amen. Beautiful. And the Bible talks
about in Matthew 15:27
about the Canaanite woman casting. What
does she say? Yes, Lord. Even the little
dogs eat the crumbs which fall from
their master's table.
>> Yeah. So, and it was just an
illustration of course and the Gentiles,
they didn't want to share those
wonderful truths about Jesus. Um, thank
you. All right, Pastor John.
>> This is a little lengthy question.
The name Michael occurs many times in
the Bible and has usually been
associated with Jesus Christ.
But where in the Bible does it clearly
point out that Christ and Michael are
one and the same? First Thessalonians
4:16 says, "For the Lord himself will
descend from heaven with a shout, with
the voice of the archangel and the
trumpet of God, and the dead in Christ
will rise first." And Jude 9 states,
"Yet Michael, the archangel in
contending with the devil, when he
disputed about the body of Moses, dared
not bring against him a reviling
accusation, but said, "The Lord rebuke
you."
>> In neither of these verses does it
clearly identify Christ and Michael as
the same being. Could you please clarify
it? This is from Ronald who sent a text
message.
>> Okay, thank you Ronald. A beautiful
question. Actually, I have an entire
study. I'm going to post it to my
website, johnlomck.com.
Just go into studies and you'll be able
to download a three-page full study.
Like sometimes Shelley says, read the
book Spotless because this time is not
adequate.
>> But I'm going to just kind of hit some
very key points. The word there,
Michael, comes from the Greek word
arguel, which means the chief of the
angels. I might not be saying that
correctly. Archelius or Argelios, which
means the chief of the angels. Now, when
it talks about the two scriptures that
you quoted, those were evidence
scriptures of the fact that Jesus is in
fact uh Michael the Archangel. Prime
example when Jesus returns with the
voice of the archangel asked the
question is Jesus going to have to
borrow another angel's voice to call the
dead to life when he is the resurrection
and the life
>> these are just logical questions is
Jesus going to say hey Michael I need
your voice I'm going back to get the
people out of the grave no he is the
resurrection and the life he called
Lazarus from the grave and the Bible
says he's going to call the sleeping
saints from the grave so when The Bible
says the Lord himself shall des the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the archangel.
Meaning the one who is above the angels.
And why the word angel? When you go to
the Old Testament, you find in the Old
Testament, Jesus is often called the
angel of the Lord. Vitally important
that you look that up. And these are
scriptures that really bring out uh
clearly. For example, in Exodus 3 2-6,
it says, "And the angel of the Lord
appeared to Moses in a flame of fire
from the midst of a bush."
And what did the angel say? Then it goes
on, "And God called him from the bush."
Right away, that angel is referred to as
as God. So clearly, this is not a
reference to, "Well, the angel's there,
but God is going to speak for him." No.
No. And then you find in the Old
Testament the word describing Jesus's
pre incarnation is Yahweh. Often that's
why he said to the Jews before Abraham
was I am. But let me go ahead and give
you something that's probably going to
tie it up for you. You find in
Revelation 12 7-11. This is one of the
largest pictures of the great
controversy from its inception to its to
its end. Revelation 12:7. And there was
war in heaven. Now when you look at that
phrase throughout time, every time there
was a controversy, including Satan, it
was with Christ you have in heaven. And
then in the garden through the serpent,
the Lord told him, "I'm going to defeat
you. I'm going to crush your head.
You're going to bruise my heel." In the
garden when Jesus was in the wilderness,
when Jesus was being tempted at the
cross, he tried to defeat Jesus by
giving him cheap Romans wine and and
sour vinegar and then trying to keep
Jesus in the grave. And Jesus rose
again. And now Revelation puts it all
together very quickly. Hear me out.
>> And there was war in heaven. Michael and
his angels fought against the dragon.
And the dragon and his angels, there
only two sides. Christ won and Satan,
this is the great controversy, and
prevailed not, neither was their place
found in heaven any longer. And the
great dragon was cast out, that serpent
of old called the devil and Satan, which
deceived the whole world. He was cast to
the earth, and his angels were cast out
with him. Now it changes to who is this
Michael that fought against him? Listen
to what happens.
>> Verse 10. And I heard a loud voice
saying, "In heaven, now has come
salvation and strength, and the kingdom
of our God, and the power of his Christ,
Michael, right away is associated with
Christ. For the accuser of our brethren
is cast down, who accused them before
our God day and night, and they overcame
him by the blood of the lamb, and by the
word of their testimony, and they love
not their lives to the death." Michael,
Christ, blood of the lamb, same
individual. M
>> very good.
>> Amen. Well said. Yeah. Beautiful. Thank
you, pastor.
>> Okay, Pastor Mooney.
>> Jesus spoke on fasting in Matthew 6
verse 16 to 18. Is it mandatory to fast?
Do we have to fast weekly? This is from
Leo.
Leo. Well, good question.
The Bible doesn't seem to indicate
fasting as mandatory,
but it seems highly encouraged like you
brought out that Jesus doesn't say if
you fast, but when you fast. Throughout
the Bible, there are examples of people
fasting with positive outcomes. You
know, I know science is actually
confirming positive physical benefits
from intermittent fasting. And of
course, there are the spiritual
advantages also.
And it does seem to be that the custom
was fasting on a weekly basis. When we
read in Luke 18:12 where the Pharisee
that stood there and he's thanking God
prayed thus with himself, it says, "God,
I thank thee that I'm not like other men
are,
>> extortioners, unjust, adulterers, and
even as this publican, I fast twice in a
week," and so forth. Well, we read here
in Luke 5:33.
And they said unto him, this is the
Pharisees jumping on Jesus.
They said unto him to Jesus, why do the
disciples of John fast often and make
prayers? And likewise, the disciples of
the Pharisees, but thine eat and drink.
So from this verse, it doesn't seem or
sound like Jesus and his disciples
necessarily fasted regularly.
In Ecclesiastes 10:17, it says, "Blessed
is the land when thy princes eat in due
season for strength and not for
drunkenness." So, it sounds like
temperance is a key. In Isaiah 58:3-5,
it speaks of wrong motives for fasting.
Where have we fasted and thou hast not
seen? Meaning, how come you didn't see
me? I was doing all this. Behold, ye
fast for strife and debate and to smite
with a fist of wickedness.
>> Is it a fast that I have chosen? So, in
other words, he said nothing to do with
that one. So, in verses 6 to8, it brings
out the correct reason for fasting. Is
not this the fast that I have chosen to
loose the bands of wickedness, to undo
the heavy burdens, and to let the
oppressed go free, and that ye break
every yoke. Is it not to deal thy bread
to the hungry, and that thou bring the
poor that are cast out to thy house?
When thou seeest the naked, that thou
cover him, and that thou hide not
thyself from thine own flesh. Then shall
thy light spring bring spring bring
forth as a morning, and thine health
shall spring forth speedily, and thy
righteousness shall go before thee. The
glory of the Lord shall be thy rear
reward." The chapter continues on all
the positive things that come from this
type of fasting. And from this text, it
sounds like fasting can actually involve
more than just eating or drinking. I
recently prayed with a caller who
informed me that she was on a media
fast. And I thought, well, that's
interesting.
>> So, it makes a difference on a person's
motives, but definitely there are
positive benefits to fasting.
>> Yes, that's true. And you said a media
fast. Some people have gone on a
Facebook fast. I've seen that before,
too. Yeah, cuz those things are so
addictive. So, thank you, pastor, for
that. Okay, Shelly,
did Jesus go to heaven soon after his
resurrection? He said to Mary, "Do not
touch me. I have not yet ascended to my
father." That seems as if he went to
heaven and returned to earth, then had a
visible return to heaven where the angel
spoke to the disciples. This is from
Candace in North Carolina.
>> And Candace in North Carolina, you are
on the right track. On the morning of
his resurrection, Jesus said to Mary
Magdalene, found in John 20:17, "Do not
cling to me, for I've not yet ascended
to my father." He had not yet presented
himself to the father as the risen
sacrifice. Now later on the same day in
Matthew 28 and verse 9, Jesus allowed
the other women who were on the road to
hold his feet indicating that something
had changed. So Christ had briefly
ascended to the father to present his
completed sacrifice once for all and
receive assurance of acceptance
on behalf of humanity. And we see that
in Hebrews 9:11.
Now Jesus remained 40 days on the earth
after his resurrection appearing
repeatedly to his disciples. We find
Acts 1:3. He presented himself alive
after his suffering by many infallible
proofs, having been seen by them during
40 days. Luke 24:44-49
says during that time he taught them
about the kingdom of God. He opened the
understanding of the scriptures and he
prepared them for mission. And then at
the end of the 40 days, he ascended
visibly from the Mount of Olives while
his disciples watched. We find this in
Acts 1:9. While they watched, he was
taken up and a cloud received him out of
their sight. And then two angels
declared in Acts 1:11, "This same Jesus
who was taken up from you into heaven
will so come in like manner as you saw
him go into heaven."
So his public ascension mark Christ
entrance, if you will, into his high
priestly ministry in heaven. We find
this in Hebrews 8:1 and2. And his return
will be visible and personal just as his
ascension was. It is literal. It is
bodily visible. His second coming will
be the same. Revelation 17, behold his
coming with clouds and every eye will
see him. Now that really stands in
contrast, doesn't it to the idea of the
invisible return theories. So Christ's
return is going to be glorious. It is
going to be unmistakable,
invisible worldwide.
>> And it won't be a secret, will it?
>> No secret.
>> Every eye shall see him. Thank you,
Shelly. Maybe you've just tuned in and
you say, "Hm, I'd like to send a
question in." You can do so. You can
email us by going to bibleqa3abn.tv.
Or if you want to text us, you can send
a text to 6182283975.
Maybe you're on an Instagram person. You
can send an Instagram message you by
going to 3ABN
official. So those are three ways you
can send your questions and send them
in. We have a wonderful panel that will
go to the word of God and answer the
questions from the Bible. Okay. Thank
you, Pastor John. Here's your final
question. Can you explain the being
taken and left behind in Matthew 24:4-41
and Luke 17:34-36.
This is from Lee in Texas.
>> Yes, Lee, thank you for the question.
I'm going to read those two scriptures
and just go ahead and show you what the
Bible says. Matthew 24:4 and 41. Ah, I'm
going to go further back because 40 and
41 is the ending of the story, not the
full context. Let me read you Matthew
24:37
38 then 39 40 41 all the way to 44.
>> It's always important to get context,
right? My pastor.
>> Amen.
>> People read these texts to just build a
wall, but it's like building a wall
without any concrete.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's look at the full story. Here's the
context of those verses. But as the days
of Noah were, verse 37 of Matthew 24, so
also will the coming of the Son of Man
be. For as in the days before the flood,
they were eating and drinking, marrying
and giving in marriage. Here's the key.
Until the day that Noah entered the ark,
and did not know until the flood came
and took them all away, so also will the
coming of the Son of Man be.
>> The flood did not take the wicked to
safety. It took them in destruction. Now
let's read. So now the Lord talks about
how that's going to happen.
>> Verse 40. Then two men will be in the
field, one taken, the other left. Two
women grinding in the mill, one taken,
the other left. And then he says, this
is so vitally important. Watch
therefore,
for you do not know what hour the son of
man comes. He is saying, therefore, be
also ready, for the son of man is coming
at an hour you do not expect. Now
if there was going to be a second chance
which is often connected to it you
wouldn't have to worry about it if taken
like the common teaching is meant you
all gone to heaven and there are those
who are left behind like this entire
series called left behind
>> by the way the only thing left behind is
the truth
this would mean oh well I don't have to
worry about it I don't have to be
careful what the hour is going to be
because hey you know pastor Maronei left
I got a second chance
>> now let's nail this coffin down Luke
chapter 20 Luke chapter 17 pulls us back
into the story the same context Luke
17:34
to 37
I tell you in that night there will be
two men in one bed one will be taken the
other left two women will be grind at
the mill one will be taken the other
left two men will be in the field the
one will be taken and the other left and
now a direct question verse 37 and they
answered and said to him where Lord in
other words take in where
>> and here's the answer. So we said to
them wherever the body is there the
eagles will be gathered together.
>> That's the great supper of the great day
of God Almighty. The evidence of that is
the eagles are going to be gathered
wherever they are taken. Like in the
days of Noah the flood took them. That's
where they were. Here's Revelation
chapter 19. Then I saw an angel standing
in the sun, and he cried with a loud
voice, saying to all the birds that fly
in heaven, "Come and gather together for
the great supper of the great day of
God, that you may eat the flesh of
kings, the flesh of captains, the flesh
of mighty men, the flesh of horses, and
those who sit on them, and the flesh of
all people, free and slave, both small
and great. They are not taken to a safe
place. They're taken to a dinner you you
don't want to be a part of."
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Boy, you said that. That's a lot.
>> It's a lot. I hope you
>> That's the dinner you don't want to be a
part of.
>> Yeah. No, you don't.
>> You know, I say it this way. You are
either gonna eat the dinner
>> or be
>> or you are the dinner.
>> We want to eat the dinner. How about
you? That's right.
>> Okay. I hear those amens. Amen. Okay.
Pastor Maronei,
it has been said that some people like
me do not love themselves.
If there is a scripture that says we
should love ourselves, please help me
find it. This is from Carl.
>> Well, Carl, I appreciate your candidness
in this question.
>> I'm sure there's others are wondering
the same thing.
>> There does seem to be a dichotomy in the
Bible regarding loving ourselves.
>> Let me start with this thought. When God
created man, he gave him a totally
selfless nature. His love was a selfless
love. When Adam chose to be selfish, his
nature changed and he became selfish.
And he passed that trait on to his
posterity. So you and I have this
selfish bent in our characters. We're
totally unable to fix ourselves from our
selfish natures. John 1 and verse14
tells us that Jesus was made flesh and
dwelt among us and we beheld his glory.
The glory as the only begotten of the
father full of grace and truth. This
glory is speaking of his character.
Jesus lived a totally selfless life. He
did as a descendant of Adam. In other
words, in our flesh, his demonstration
of God's selfless love is our only hope
to be changed from our selfish natures.
Our natures are changed by what we
behold. 2 Corinthians 3:18, "But we all
with open face, beholding as in a glass
or a mirror, the glory of the Lord or
the character of the Lord are changed
into the same image from glory to glory,
even as by the spirit of the Lord." Now
Carl coming back to your question
regarding a scripture about loving
ourselves in Matthew 22:29 it says this
is where he's talking about the
commandments you know the great
commandments you know love God and this
one is about the second one is liken to
it thou shalt love thy neighbor as
thyself
so if we don't love ourselves
or we look at it what God created you
know God created each one of us.
>> Um, then how can we love our neighborh
>> and or if we think badly of ourselves,
then we're probably going to think badly
of our neighborh.
>> I believe there is a healthy kind of
love where we appreciate God creating us
and have respect for his creation.
>> Yes.
>> I like to think of it this way, Carl.
God created me. He tells me he's loved
me with an everlasting love.
>> That's right.
>> And his with his loving kindness. He's
drawing me to himself. So rather than
focusing on me, I focus on what he says
about me.
>> This is how we're going to be changed.
If we focus on ourselves,
we are all a mess. Romans 3:23 tells us,
"For all have sinned and come short of
the glory of God."
And Jesus says in Isaiah 45:22,
"Look unto me and be ye saved, all the
ends of the earth." So he's the perfect
one who loves and is love. Totally
selfless. So we focus upon him all the
ends of the earth. And God, he says he's
God and there's none else.
Carl, let me leave you with this phrase.
Do not think less of yourself. That's
right.
>> But think of yourself less.
>> That's good.
>> Say it again.
>> It is.
>> Do not think less of yourself.
Think of yourself less
>> again. Thank you, Carl. God loves you.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you for that. You all loved
Carl. Jesus gave everything. If you were
the only one in this earth, he would
have died for you.
remember that. You may say, "Oh, I've
done this. I've done that." He's
forgiven you when you confess
your sins to him. Thank you so much for
that.
>> Okay, Shellyley.
In 1 Corinthians 15:51-52
speaks of the resurrection and the
transformation of our physical bodies
from corruptible to incorruptible.
The passage also mentions that the dead
in Christ will be raised and changed. My
question is, is there a specific or
average age we will be when we are
transformed? For example, will those who
died of old age or as children have the
same glorified form? I find it hard to
imagine that we will all appear as we
will all appear the same as we were at
death. This is from Ron in Thailand.
>> Ron, thank you for this question and let
me
>> we're going to begin with 1 Corinthians
15:51-53.
Reading this because some people don't
know what it says. Paul writes and says,
"Behold, I tell you a mystery. We shall
not all sleep, but we shall all be
changed in a moment, in the twinkling of
an eye, at the last trumpet. For the
trumpet will sound, and the dead will be
raised incorruptible, and we shall be
changed. For this corruptible must put
on incorruption.
This mortal must put on immortality. And
this happens when Christ returns. So
scripture does not give a numerical age
um for our glorified bodies. But what it
does do is describes a perfection that
is restored when we have our glorified
body. When we put on this immortality,
incorruption, that word means to be free
from decay, free from disease,
weakness or incompleteness.
So in going further in first Corinthians
or going backward in 1 Corinthians
15:42-44,
Paul says the resurrection of the body
of the dead is like this. The body is
sown in corruption, raised in
incorruption. Sown in dishonor, raised
in glory. Sown in weakness, raised in
power. Sown a natural body.
>> And then we are raised a spiritual body
at the last trump.
>> So what this is talking about is total
restoration. It's going to be the
perfection of the Garden of Eden by
God's original design. And if you think
about this, Adam and Eve were fully
developed. They were mature. They were
vigorously mature.
>> So, in my mind, this rules out infancy
>> or old age. If you're thinking about
you're not going to have any limitations
because both of those reflect the
earth's imitation uh limitation.
So the restoration of God's original
design suggests that children will be
resurrected to full maturity. The aged
will be restored to full strength
>> without wrinkles, without any bad
joints. Hallelujah. And it aligns within
this framework. Christ glorified body is
our pattern. It he it is physical. It is
real. Free from death and limitations.
And he says in Philippians 3:21, he will
transform our lowly body that it may be
conformed to his glorious body. Jesus
was recognizable when he was raised from
the dead. Moses and Elijah were
recognizable at the mount of
transfiguration. So, we're not going to
lose our individual identity and
recognition, but we'll be changed.
>> I read somewhere that we we will know
each other by our tone of our voice cuz
we'll look so beautiful and
>> oh, Christlike. Thank you so much. What
we're going to do is take a short break
and we will be right back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
>> Welcome back. We're I'm going to ask our
panelists for a few closing thoughts.
We're going to start with Sister Shelley
Quinn.
>> I just wanted to add one scripture to
what I was talking about uh what we're
going to be when we're resurrected. 1
John 3:2. Beloved, now we are children
of God, and it has not yet been revealed
what we shall be, but we know that when
he is revealed, we shall be like him.
>> Hallelujah.
>> Amen.
>> My favorite scripture.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Pastor,
>> well, thank you for sending those
questions. It was really fun answering
those questions, digging in there. I
just want to leave that thought for I
guess it was Carl that uh you know,
we're imprinted as we're children
growing up. You know, there's people say
all kinds of stuff to us and we get as
this imprint of our own what we think
about ourselves. So, think about that,
too.
>> Amen. Thank you.
>> That's right. And when it comes to the
taken and left, the Bible always talks
about the wicked shall be cut off.
Proverbs 21 and 22 and Psalm 37:10 and
11. Yet a little while and the wicked
shall be no more. And so, we see that
the cutting off, the taken away is the
wicked are removing being removed from
the scene. And the Lord is making space
for the righteous and the meek will
inherit the earth. So choose the Lord
and you'll be on the safe side.
>> All right. Thank you. I hope you were
blessed. I was blessed. Psalm 119 verse
11, your word. Let's say it together. I
have hidden within my heart that I might
not sin against you. Have a blessed day
in Jesus.